special Tomorrowland themed Disney logo
expects me to forget the 30 second
stolen from my life this is a story
about the future just because Clooney's
face is in the picture doesn't make this
not narration environmental collapse you
please just stop interrupting the
screenwriter of this movie would be
excellent at cinema since curiously and
closer I can't tell them anything until
like skip its official everyone working
at Hollywood had some formative
experience with the World's Fair back in
the day and it led to every screenplay
ever written
this kid survives this I would your
jetpack make the world a better place
can't it just be fun okay first of all
that this judge can't see the practical
implementations of a working jetpack
second of all that this kid who invented
it can't describe one practical
application of a personal flying machine
who are you I'm the future Frank Walker
that is not an acceptable answer to
anyone not living inside a movie what is
there an empty ass boat floating down
the water here is that the rescue boat
in case the one in front gets attacked
by the communists also good to see 1960s
World's Fair security is roughly
equivalent to modern-day security at a
49ers game helmets are hung at a height
just so this ride will injure little
kids
I think roald dahl designed this
transport well I guess falling is no
longer concern in this realm a robot
accidentally turns this kid into the
racketeer for two seconds kid falling to
his death stops to admire the view
just how Athena planned it because if
you think you could tell the story
better I would absolutely love to hear
you try I would too futuristic movie
steals the beginning scene of just about
every paranormal activity gonna go
through your entire childhood this
argument is not endearing she's outside
a perimeter fence about to operate an RC
helicopter but she decides to do it
bathed in all the light and allegedly
this is a NASA launch platform so
security is minimal iPhone product
leasman could feel more force to be
tried wait what kind of security fence
is this it just curves outward no spikes
or razor wire at the top or nothing
just a gentle slope I mean no wonder
right why would you remove your helmet
and hood immediately after landing in
the property you're trying to stealthily
infiltrate sure let's get distracted by
stars while you're on the restricted
NASA launch site movie shows me the
daemon looper kid mere minutes after
showing me the one kid who played young
Noah on heroes movie is trying to give
me a stroke solely from evil
child actors even the teen east of
actions could change the future well I
shouldn't Kuchar from butterfly effect
believes you but Bruce Willis from 12
monkeys does not and I'm gonna have to
go I chose to time travel example actors
who were both married to Demi Moore I
swear to God I didn't do that on purpose
discount Tim - holy fucking crap yeah
Eddie noon sure Newton's is last name
might as well called this guy in Stein
mixed weird girl who sabotage NASA
platforms keeps hesitating for some
reason in taking a single bite of that
Apple in her hand smart girl keeps doing
that because maybe she wants to get
caught she's a serial killer and waiting
once again Athena just expects people to
know what to do it like this discount
Emerald City what's the point of being
transported to a different place if
you're constrained by the limitations of
the original place
Diane handcuffs is allowed to interact
with people talk and do stuff normal
prisoners are not allowed to do no idea
of the strings I had to pull to keep
Homeland Security from pressing charges
Casey well what did you have to blow
someone you seemed to be well beyond
retired so what kind of favors can you
even call it at this point hey general
I'll sing at your daughter's wedding if
you look the other way on this one
what's that yes Jesus I'll bring my wife
okay
why is always daytime in this field no
matter what time it is on earth when she
touches this now she knows she's
constrained by where her body actually
is and she still does this in her dad's
room and this magically transporting pin
isn't both also I think this is a nasty
Anna fall to send the fact that she
survives this Casey is absolutely sure
that she can navigate through the other
world by traveling in this world which
doesn't make sense considering she
appeared in virtually all the same spots
from the jail from the car and from the
house wait are you telling me she
eyeballed that distance from her own
front yard that's amazing how many
people have died using this pin
transporter a lot right we're in the
middle of a five-minute unbroken shot
which would feel a lot more impressive
if I didn't feel like I was getting
broken every time the camera moved to
look at some heavy amounts of green
screen and special effect
this guy's digital futuristic newspaper
is still rigid in form and not remotely
pliable or paper-like well this is
essentially the same set guardians of
the galaxy used for the scene where all
the guardians are arrested at once as
all for 13 Asst if it had kept going for
a few seconds longer and then given out
you would drown just FYI
you're looking for a collectible pin
with a tee on it shouldn't be too hard
to find that very specific one on eBay
also just type in vintage round pins and
they come up in no time
give me their number Jesus can't you
look at the screen could you please tell
me one case you will be back aren't you
following her around what is your deal
that you follow someone around give them
a mysterious pin leave and then come
back at some random time with no clue of
their whereabouts don't ask me how I
know your name I know it the same way I
know that you are lying to me but you
can't figure out where the hell Casey
went because you're omniscient until you
are aren't you
from the future you clearly understand
so why aren't you telling me what I need
to know because up until now you've been
creepy and showed no evidence you were
some sort of future girl until you told
Nathan his name you're a robot logic
already Casey goes looking for
information about a future teleportation
pin at a store dedicated to a largely
forgettable Brendan Fraser movie I see
you Luke Skywalker uniforms lately
placed in the background and I'm not
gonna fall for your subliminal bull Brad
Bird manages to pimp the Iron Giant in
this expensive Disney movie now I really
want to watch The Iron Giant as opposed
to this this movie's true comic geek
nerd expert hides in his geek shop
behind Star Trek doors that are
musically linked to Star Wars music and
which looked like a robot's vagina it's
10:30 in the morning and I'm honestly
surprised Casey is up and Adam this
early and that the nerdy geek store is
open and its employees or even a week I
saw that you were looking for one on the
road you get it wait a minute you mean
you found a store that was merely
looking for this pin as opposed to
actually selling them is that how he be
works why would you go to the store for
information anyway does there need imply
transportation knowledge people this
serious about finding a collectible pin
on a small store in Houston and hope
people see their one ad on eBay also
this movie just jumped them in and black
athina ex machina also how did she get
here in time she's not using any kind of
futuristic transport to get from Cape
Canaveral to Houston in ten minutes and
yeah she could run really fast but not
like Florida to Texas to save somebody
fast why is that fit well you got a
ridiculous bloody nose that no previous
scene even hinted at that's what
happened and I do wish you hadn't run
off before I had a chance
give you some rather necessary contact
are you serious is this how future pan
exchanges work let's just give this girl
a transporting pin while she's locked up
in jail
leave no notes and expect her to just
wait around for a mysterious person they
do not know exists to come by and
explain it to them how often does that
work in what world can someone reach the
break from the passenger side especially
when they're like 5 foot 3 once again
movie driver apparently can't see a
goddamn person walking across the street
and just plows right into the Texas man
luckily no one is around to see these
three cops get vaporized right after the
store exploded but just isn't anyone
who's curious in the city of Houston
totally found the girl in what world
have you found the girl you found
evidence of the girl but you have no
clue where she went after that
recruitment for what I know slide to
answer that well that's convenient for
the movie's plot considering all the
crap you've already told her so far
we're about an hour in and we're still
pretty much in the dark about what is
going on in this movie they've been
driving a stolen truck for a really long
time and absolutely no cops have pulled
them over for that or the smashed
windshield also does this girl have like
tons of money stashed away to go on huge
road trips like this Casey I know you
have no reason to trust me I know you
have no reason to trust me so you should
trust me cliche the audience should now
care about the memories of a robot girl
who once played that paper choosing game
with Frank terrified girl somehow has
the wherewithal to notice that this dog
isn't leaving paw prints I mean I know
she's a genius but that is some crazy to
notice hop digital dog this guy who has
a hologram guard dog and a thing that
knocks you the fuck out when you're at
his door doesn't have any other security
beyond that when it comes to his secret
satellite hoarding place only when Casey
sets the tractor on fire does this guy's
security wake up again and that is an
oddly specific reason for the alarm to
go off when she's been walking all over
the property hmm that's a pretty good
fire extinguisher he's invented and not
shared with the world what a dick the
next couple of minutes of film will be
brought to you by hologram technology I
mean he has a hologram guard dog that
looks real for Christ's sake couldn't
you just have something like that to
play his home movies Wow I'd make a quip
about this clock timer countdown thing
being ripped off from lost except
Lindelof actually wrote this script so I
think whatever statement I make about it
would need to include the word self and
plagiarism
oh look he has a secret way in he just
waited forever to use it for some reason
it's except that there is a world where
I know with absolute certainty the exact
time of your death it seems like this
movie should have been sliding into the
end of its first act right about here
instead they wasted 15 minutes on these
two interrupting each other about how
the story should be told in another 45
when confusing feature pin technology
before they finally got here
shudders are wired to go down one by one
and not all at the same time so people
starting on one side of the house still
actually have a chance to break in after
the buttons push I'd like to point out
that by merely making these hundred
people robots instead of humans the film
was able to get away with violently
stabbing one of them to death in the
chest
and ripping one's head clean off without
it affecting the NPA's rating oh you
mean this one area the house has magnets
that's amazing
are you saying she didn't hit him enough
times with the bat to keep him from
doing this and Frank whose experience
with these robots literally said that's
enough
but whatever sometimes an action
sequence just needs some bull attention
I know right and somehow not prepared
for the old flaming tracker routine you
use to sneak inside my hat later back no
I can't go without it having a lucky
something you can't live without oh good
Athena's back why did she leave again
did she have to go do research on the
One Ring move over you know I think this
movie missed a real opportunity right at
this moment to turn this thing into a
road trip bill think about it a cranky
old inventor a plucky teenage girl in a
sarcastic child robot all in a crap you
pick up driving from one coast to
another imagine the wacky adventures
they'd have wait are they just gonna let
the girl robot that is obviously 10
years old drive the truck in broad
daylight like no one's gonna see that
report it
you still think you're recruiting dubbed
you 50 minutes until the credits and
we're still in the dark about what this
movie is about we need to get to the
spectacle spectacle this isn't the
pronoun game but it's the pronoun game
and it's expositionally pissing me off
I'd like to explain everything
of may move on scooby speaks directly to
the audience is coke in the fridge you
haven't been here in more than 25 years
ago ting to this movie I think both the
fridge and the coke or well past their
time she stole the coke in tender for
Frank and he just carries on like he too
did not lose 90 percent of his blood
sugar in the trip and even if he has
experience with this it was 40 years ago
dude should be doubled over in a cone
eating fetal position right now they
were a part of all this
I fucked Jules Verne Tesla mr. Edison so
this movie is saying Tesla and Edison
willingly cooperated together on a
science thing do you think this movie
realizes how national treasure it's
gotten at this point because I don't
think it does luckily for the story and
the film's rating all the humans here at
this moment are only standing on the
perimeter down here come on also on
guessing the ship has never been used
but sure it still works after hundreds
of years because the future this guard
seems very concerned about three dudes
running up the Eiffel Tower but was in
no way troubled by the Eiffel Tower
splitting in two to make way for a rock
at a minute ago why does it rocket have
glass windows okay hold the phone
Clooney and the girl acted as though
they've done this before but the wait
Paris is reacting this is unprecedented
but even if it was 40 years ago if the
apple tower had separated for a blue
rocket launch that would be well known
today unless they use that Jupiter
ascending magic ball that's no one think
they're about to die god damn it society
look this woman here and this dude are
filming in portrait instead of landscape
and this chick here is using a goddamn
iPad to film video none of this is
acceptable I feel like we just went
through this they took one transport
just to get to Paris now they're in a
shuttle they launch from the Apple tower
because apparently this can't be cool
unless they get to use a famous monument
in the process well we got a brief
glimpse earlier movie called
Tomorrowland will beat one hour in 26
minutes to actually spend any real time
in Tomorrowland
I suspect the effects budget was at
least part of the reason now one you
tell me seriously he agreed to go on
this trip without discussing what they
would do before they arrived don't you
feel like the whole screenplay was
written like this well you wanted to see
Tomorrowland roll credits right how the
fuck do you recognize a 40 years older
version of Frank that's maybe more
impressive than any other thing shown in
this movie I think she can fix it David
we are now thirty minutes away from the
credits and we still don't know what the
it is she doesn't know what it is either
seems like that could have been
discussed before they got here but
better to keep everyone in the dark
world miss Newton he thinks you could
fix
the world well I don't know about you
but I started drinking a half hour ago
so this is plenty enough explanation for
me bring on the crazy
what are those flashes of future we got
him on loan from contact impressed
futuristic monitor station is basically
cerebro trained terrorists Lee is
married yesterday
she knows nothing's work it's amazing
how unearned this feels we saw her
sabotage and NASA launching pad she asks
questions at school but nothing so far
to show that she really knows how things
work this is three days ago maybe if
you'd just some books in Morse code
you'll be able to tell your past self
not to go Wow I almost believe these
people are standing on a floating
platform above a flooded neighborhood
except it looks like you they're not
gonna die this is your world not ours so
it's now I've got to ask why did that
virtual reality advertisement that she
walked through an hour ago required her
to find a real-world location to
experience it these people driven by
savagery bad guy in a sci-fi movie looks
upon all humans as savages cliche
apparently you're one ten-thousandth
variable and the inevitability wasn't
convincing enough to change his mind
movie is hammering that slim chance can
make a big difference thing hard which
means it's the horton hears a who of
time-traveling willies really are
special well as long as there's the
reason for it wait there's no reason for
it nor an explanation
well okay then you can't just zap well
you knew a movie with dr. house and it
was gonna have a dr. house aha moment
when I touch this thing for a few
minutes it felt like anything was
possible so then why can't the opposite
happen what if the monitor is just a
giant pen okay I'm just gonna ask my cat
Wallace to take it from here because
this movie has completely bewildered me
with nonsense
holy Sh is that a Stargate did they lose
their patent it isn't just receiving
tachyons it is taking a possible future
and making amplifying it transmitting it
like like a feedback it's a
self-fulfilling prophecy that they're
really questions about why this movie
bond seems pretty obviously jargon
people to death movie directed by a guy
who directed another movie about
monologuing is about to allow this bad
guy to monologue for world record amount
of time these butterflies start to
disappear the glaciers melt right
alternate-dimension maybe human race
sees earth humans being terrible and
prescribes immediate genocide because
they're evolved right it's on the
monitors fault that's yours
God I tell you my dr. house meets dr.
Doug Ross fan fiction is way the hell
better than this NYX keeps an important
plot device around his wrists so Frank
can easily access it during a handshake
this movie is barely getting Casey any
more information than it's giving me
robot ten-year-old pulls a wire too and
suddenly this movie is real steel thank
goodness for the Tachyon see the near
future Omega 13 effect that we only just
learned about a few minutes ago that I
can show Casey how to operate this bomb
but my question is how did the first
Casey through this timeline know how to
operate the ball um falling from that
height at that speed even if a robot arm
caught the platform she ded yo oh come
on and while he would have been able to
hold it this guy was the mascot for the
Prometheus school of running away from
things I mean dude that simple roll to
the left or right and you would avoid
this no and that's how he became dr.
house no wonder he's cranky
little-known fact alternate dimension
robot girls can get knocked unconscious
what so new luckily this is just the
future and for this one time it's on a
long delay so that Athena can say Frank
three things I need to type for the
final before the automated program kicks
in fortunately this program will allow
me to tell you an unabridged story about
how my AI learn to fall in love with a
human
all before I died I'm having unusual
thoughts towards front cuca they've also
led to what my AI tells me is my first
visit from Aunt Flo bot almost two full
minutes a robot Frank childhood romance
backstory I don't even care a tiny bit
about hey Casey we're about to blow up
this monitor thing so you might want to
start getting the hell out of here right
off movie stops just one pair of laser
skates shy of ripping off Jupiter
ascending on screen this time well
Athena just blew up Epcot I knew Disney
would be the cause of their own downfall
I just didn't know how
bollocks sweet KC managed to run away
from that not bloody likely
but she did not run that far to get here
that fast goddammit do your work yes we
have to make it work
you got that America we are looking for
dreamers anyone who will feed the right
wolf
well I seriously think there's half a
movie on the cutting room floor I'm so
fucking lost I'm not even sure which
faction this chick ended up choosing was
it Amity also did all the people around
them stand around for two fucking hours
listening to this story are they as
confused as we are why are the only
Tomorrowland dreamer recruiter
candidates children when recruiting the
best minds in the world will pluck you
down in the middle of day know where to
start
cities are for closers only this guy
gets a recruitment pin because he's
creative so why not get elite also it's
time to reprogram the recruit Oh bots if
one of them is just tossing out
Tomorrowland pins to any old street
musician looks like all these assholes
are getting the same unexplained pin
treatment this case he was but gonna
come with a booklet on what to do next
oh Jesus we clearly saw the windmill
field as a destination when Clooney was
sending off the recruit Oh BOTS which
means one of them merely walked up to
the first team and he found planted a
pin and called it a day lazy ass I'm
glad we could see everyone who got a pin
I would not a believe people around the
world were getting these unless they
showed me the entire roster all of them
touched it at the same time also
remember that Casey kept running into
walls and when she got her pin she had
to go to a specific place in her town in
order for the pin to take her to
Tomorrowland so why are these people
from around the world on the same place
also I can't wait to see the massive
clusterfuck of all these people not
knowing how to get to the city exactly
bumping into each other and stuff around
the house and eventually getting pissed
off at one another enough to build an
atomic bomb and make this whole movies
work useless
remember this
who are you
just a flesh wound I think this is a
game you're too young to train here and
a story now quit wasting our time get
them out of here
motivation for what we need to go back
over Frank we have to go back Kate we
have to go back all that charm and the
and the sense of purpose and the cute
little smile it's all just software from
by little ones and zeros little bits of
data it's all just electrons we're
within limits barely been asleep for
almost nine hours now this certainly is
a big round room the brainwaves of
mutants are different from average human
beings this device amplifies my power
allowing me to locate mutants across
great distances